FIRST SENATE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
YET BUT WE DO HAVE AN AUTHOR
HERE.
SO WE WILL ALLOW OUR AUTHOR TO
GO AHEAD AND PRESENT OUR FIRST
BILL SENATE BILL.
TWO FIFTY THREE RELATED TO THE
CANNELLA ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING
ACT OF NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
MORTY MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
SB TWO FIFTY THREE WOULD REQUIRE
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE.
ESTABLISHING THE MINISTER.
AN INCENTIVE BASED CONSERVATION
PROGRAM.
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
PROGRAM TO OPTIMIZE WILDLIFE
HABITAT BENEFITS WHILE
SUPPORTING THE ECONOMIC VITALITY
OF CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE.
BY PROVIDING INCENTIVES IN
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
THE FARMERS AND RANCHERS.
AGRICULTURE OBVIOUSLY IS A MAJOR
INDUSTRY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION TO VALUABLE OPEN
SPACE AND WILD LIFE HABITAT.
THE MAYES WITH DECISIONS AND
CONSERVATION PRACTICES OF
FARMERS AND RANCHERS ALSO
ENHANCE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY.
PROVIDE RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AND OFFER SOCIAL
BENEFITS.
IN RECENT YEARS THE DELIVERY OF
ON FARM CONSERVATION PRACTICES
AS THE CLIENT.
THE DECLINE IS DRIVEN BY THE
RISING COST OF AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTION INCLUDING WATER IN
ENERGY COSTS.
MORE RESOURCES AND TOOLS ARE
NEEDED FOR CALIFORNIA'S FARMERS
AND RANCHERS TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE AND PROVIDE MULTIPLE
CONSERVATION BENEFITS. TO ON
FARM PRACTICE.
THE PURPOSE OF THE INCENTIVE
BASED CONSERVATION PROGRAM IS TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
AGRICULTURE PRODUCERS.
WHO WANT TO VOLUNTARILY MAKE
WILDLIFE FRIENDLY IMPROVEMENTS
ON THEIR LET?
THE PROGRAM WOULD PROVIDE
FINANCIAL AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO AGRICULTURE
PRODUCERS TO CREATE FISH AND
WILDLIFE HABITAT.
AND PROVIDE ADDED ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS SUCH AS IMPROVED WATER.
THE EROSION CONTROL AND CONSERVE
CONSERVATION OF BROWN WATER.
OPERATION OF THE PROGRAM WOULD
BE SUBJECT TO AN APPROPRIATION
OF FUNDS BY THE LEGISLATURE.
SB TWO FIFTY THREE IS SUPPORTED
BY THE NATURE CONSERVANCY WHICH
IS HERE WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY.
FOR THE BILL.
THE MORNING TERM WOMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS LIZ FORCED BURKE AND
I AM THE ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF
POLICY FOR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY.
WE ARE HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL.
TWO FIFTY OF CALIFORNIA'S
APPROXIMATELY HUNDRED MILLION
ACRES FORTY THREE MILLION ACRES
ARGUES FOR AGRICULTURE AND HE'S
WORKING FARMS AND RANCHES
PRODUCE MUCH OF THE COUNTRY'S
FOOD AND FIBER.
THESE WORKING LADS ALSO PROVIDE
MUCH OF OUR STATES OPEN SPACE
AND HABITATS THAT WILDLIFE NEED.
SB TWO FIFTY THREE WOULD
ESTABLISH NEW PROGRAM PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCERS WANT TO VOLUNTARILY
MAKE CONSERVATION IMPROVEMENTS
ON THEIR LAND.
WITH THE HELP FROM AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING INCENTIVE
PROGRAM CREATED IN TWO FIFTY
THREE PRODUCERS WOULD BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT ON FARM PRACTICES THAT
DELIVER ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS.
SUCH AS IMPROVED WATER AIR
QUALITY CONSERVE GROUNDWATER OR
SURFACE WATER.
OR CREATED WILDLIFE HABITAT SOME
OF THESE HABITAT PROJECTS COULD
INCLUDE WILDLIFE FAMILY FARMING
FENCING THAT ALLOWS FOR SAFE
WILD LIFE MOVEMENT.
FLOODING RICE FIELDS FOR
MIGRATORY BIRD HABITAT GOOD FOR
FISH WHICH MISTER CORNWELL WHAT
WE'LL TALK ABOUT.
MORE RESOURCES AND TOOLS ARE
NEEDED FOR CALIFORNIA'S FARMERS
AND RANCHERS TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE.
SB TWO FIFTY THREE WITH SUPPORT
SCIENCE DRIVEN INVESTMENTS THE
DELIVER BENEFITS TO PUBLIC ABOVE
AND BEYOND WHAT CAN BE
REASONABLY EXPECTED THAT LENDERS
COULD PROVIDE ON THEIR OWN.
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING INCENTIVE
PROGRAM WOULD BE SIMILAR TO
USDA'S NATURAL RESOURCE
CONSERVATION SERVICE PROGRAM BUT
WOULD BE DESIGNED TO PROVIDE A
SUITE OF ON FARM PRACTICES BEST
SUITED TO ME CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE RESOURCE NEEDS.
CALIFORNIA IS THE LARGEST
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCER IN THE
STATE SHOULD DO MORE TO
INCENTIVIZE INNOVATIVE
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS THAT WILL
HAVE TANGIBLE BENEFITS FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND HELP IMPROVE OUR FARM AND
RANCH LANDS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE SIR.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
TWO FIFTY THREE MY NAME IS ROGER
CORNWELL AND ON THE GENERAL
MANAGER OF RIVER GARDEN FARMS.
RIVER GARDEN FARMS --
OWNS AND OPERATES.
OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND ACRES OF
CORN WALNUTS RICE ALFALFA.
SUNFLOWER SAFFLOWER AND WE'D ON
THE WEST SIDE OF THE SACRAMENTO
RIVER.
IN YOLO INCLUDES THE COUNTIES.
REGARDING FARM HAS BEEN FAMILY
OWNED AND OPERATED SINCE.
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR AND OUR
SECOND THIRD GENERATION OF
OWNERS ARE DEDICATED TO
PROGRESSIVE FARMING.
AND EING AN INTEGRAL PART OF
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY.
ON THE FARM THERE'S BEEN A LONG
STANDING COMMITMENT TO MANAGE.
RESOURCES AND MAKE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS FOR ECO SYSTEM
IMPROVEMENTS BOTH FISH AND
WILDLIFE.
AS A RESULT WE HAVE DIRECT
EXPENSES EXPERIENCE SORRY WITH
THE TYPES OF ACTIONS THAT THIS
BILL WOULD INCENTIVIZE AND
PROMOTE. TO BRIEFLY OUTLINE TWO
EXAMPLES OF OF ACTIONS THAT WE
HAVE TAKEN.
FIRST OUR FARMERS PARTICIPATED
IN THE TNC BIRD RETURNS PROGRAM
TO HELP OPTIMIZE.
THE WATERBERG HABITAT BENEFITS
IN ARE SEASONALLY FLOODED RICE
FIELDS.
IN ADDITION TO DECOMPOSING RICE
STRAW THIS PREPARES THE FIELDS
FOR NEXT YEAR'S PLANTING.
THIS PRACTICE PROVIDES CRITICAL
HABITAT FOR MIGRATING SHOREBIRDS
AS WELL.
SECONDLY WE CURRENTLY PARTNER
WITH CAL TROUT UC DAVIS AND
OTHERS TO DEMONSTRATE THE
ABILITY OF FLOODED RICE FIELDS
TO GROW FISH.
SO PLANKTON ANOTHER BUGS OR WHAT
WE LIKE TO CALL FLOODING PLAY.
THAT CAN BE REINTRODUCED INTO
THE SACRAMENTO RIVER FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE CHINOOK SALMON.
AND THE WIDER FOOD WEB.
RIVER GARDEN FARMS IS UNIQUE.
WITH A SUPPORTIVE PARTNERSHIP.
GROUP AND AND THE SIZE TO TAKE
ON THESE ACTIONS AT SCALE WE ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE.
AND EXPLORE NEW WAYS TO ENHANCE
FISH AND WILDLIFE HABITAT.
BUT WE ARE ALWAYS AWARE.
OF THE FACT THAT WE ARE
COMPETING IN A GLOBAL ECONOMY WE
NEED TO MAINTAIN A HIGH LEVEL OF
EFFICIENCY AND PRODUCTIVITY.
SB TWO FIFTY THREE WILL CREATE A
FRAMEWORK AT THE STATE LEVEL
THAT WILL PROMOTE ACTIONS THAT
CAN BENEFIT OUR ECONOMY.
AND THE ENVIRONMENT AS WELL AS
STREAMLINED INCENTIVES.
SO THAT ALL FARMERS CAN CONSIDER
SIMILAR OPPORTUNITIES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I'D
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND THE GROUP REPRESENTING HI MY
NAME IS KAREN BERGER I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS.
AND OUR CITIES HAVE BEEN WORKING
I HAVE SINCE THE DUST BOWL ERA
TO ADDRESS ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS ON AG PROPERTY.
SO THEY'VE BEEN MAKING SURE THAT
FARMERS HAVE ACCESS BOTH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PRACTICES AND ALSO --
KEEPING AG STRONG.
ENOUGH FOR OVER SEVENTY FIVE
YEARS CULTURE AS PART OF THIS
ENVIRONMENTAL SOLUTION THROUGH
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH NATURAL
RESOURCE CONSERVATION SERVICE.
AND WE FEEL LIKE HAVING AN
ANALOG HERE IN THE STATE IT
WOULD BE REALLY CRITICAL TO
MAKING SURE THEY WERE ABLE TO
EXPAND THAT.
PARTICULARLY IN THE AREAS OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
WON'T WORK INCLUDING CLIMATE
CHANGE AND CANNABIS AND SOME OF
THE OTHER.
THINGS THAT THAT THEY WON'T THEY
ARE ABLE TO WORK AND SO WE FEEL
LIKE CREATING INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE CALIFORNIA
SPECIFIC.
IS REALLY CRITICAL TO THE FUTURE
OF OUR STATE COMBATING CLIMATE
CHANGE AND REALLY I'M MOVING
ENVIRONMENT AND NECK BOTH
FORWARD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE LARA KNOWING HE
TOOK ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RICE COMMISSION IN SUPPORT. FOR
ME GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF OR
MEMBERSHIP OF A WATER SUPPLIERS
LANDOWNERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SACRAMENTO VALLEY INCLUDING
RIVER GARDEN FARMS WE SUPPORT
THE MEASURE WE THINK THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS FOR BRING IT
FORWARD.
YES PRIVATE.
MORNING MADAM CHAIRWOMAN MEMBERS
MARK SMITH ON BEHALF THE
GRASSLAND WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT ALSO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
BUT HAVE ARE ASKING FOR AN
AMENDMENT --
THAT SMALL AMENDMENT JUST REFERS
TO AN EXISTING SECTION OF THE
WATER CODE --
WHERE WE TALK ABOUT WHAT WE DO
WITH IDLED LANDS AND TERMS OF
CREATING HABITAT VALUES AND HAVE
TALKED TO THE SPONSORS ABOUT
THAT WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SAYING NINE DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YES SENATOR CAMEO I HAVE I HAVE
A QUESTION THE LAST COMMENT ON
BY MISTER SMITH WITHIN RECALL
REGARDS --
TO AN AMENDMENT IN AB WASN'T
CLEAR TO ME WHETHER.
AMENDMENT IT WAS AGREEABLE OR
WHETHER IT WAS --
IS STILL UNDER DISCUSSION --
WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR TO BE TAKEN
COMMITTEE TODAY AND WORK
PERFECTLY CAPABLE BUT
COMFORTABLE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR THE SPONSORS THAT'S GREAT
WE JUST HEARD ABOUT IT SO --
WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK --
WITH THEM OKAY VERY GOOD THAT'S
GREAT I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I
THINK THAT.
THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE.
ON RICE.
FIELDS IS REALLY A TREMENDOUS --
TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MAKE BENCH THINGS HAPPEN
THAT ARE ALL.
THAT ALL WORK TOGETHER AND THIS
SITE THE NEW FISH FISH FOOD
PROJECT AND IT WAS NEW TO ME
LAST YEAR --
IS TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT REALLY
THANK YOU FOR THAT SO
[inaudible]
WE SHOULD.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS --
FIRST WE NEED TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM SO THAT WILL THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS GALGIANI HERE A JOURNEY
HERE WILK [inaudible]
WELL.
BILLS.
I APPRECIATE IS THAT ARE REALLY.
HAVE A HERO.
GLAZER HERE.
THANK YOU AND NOW WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND VOTE TO ADOPT THE
COMMITTEE WILL.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE COMMITTEE RULES.
LETTERS GALGIANI AYE DADDY I
WILL.
WILK I HAVE A HERO.
DOUBLE ZERO I GLAZER GLAZER II
[inaudible]
AND NOW BY SENATOR DODD THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE WON'T.
NEED A MOTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SB TWO FIFTY THREE THE MOTION IS
DO PASSING A RE REFER TO NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER.
SENATORS GALGIANI AYE GALGIANI
AYE WILK.
WILK I HAVE A GYRO.
CABALLERO AYE GLAZER GLAZER UP
HIGH.
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS.
AND THAT I HAD WORKED AT THAT
CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS FOR THE
SENATE AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A VACANCY